payet l'organisation mondiale de la
santé se dit très inquiète concernant
l'évolution de la grippe aviaire qui
pourrait provoquer une pandémie d'une
même ampleur que la grippe espagnole de
1918 l'élaborateur française américain
tente actuellement de mettre au point un
vaccin trade avec montée des poulets
manipuler avec des précautions extrêmes
ils finiront tous à l'incinérateur
depuis l'apparition de la grippe aviaire
50 millions de volailles ont dû être
abattus mais le pire est à venir car
aujourd'hui à bangkok
les experts réunis par l' oms annonce
des chiffres très pessimiste selon eux
si le virus parvient à muter s'ils
arrivent à se transmettre d'homme à
homme
2 à 7 millions de personnes pourraient
mourir un milliard contracterait la
maladie une épidémie mondiale une
pandémie
non aucun pays ne sera épargné quand ce
sera devenue bandit alors ce n'est pas
le problème d'un pays c'est le problème
de tous les pays et justement de
laboratoire un américain et un français
ont déjà commencé à fabriquer un vaccin
ici à lyon un millier de doses
expérimentales sont déjà prêtes
premier essai sur l'homme début 2005 en
cas d'épidémie mondiale l'industrie
suivra dans ce contexte nous serions
capables de traduire des centaines de
millions de doses en premier temps il
nous faudrait environ quatre à six mois
mais en quatre à six mois plusieurs
milliers de personnes pourraient mourir
le défi de demain identifiés et annoncer
rapidement d'éventuels foyers humain de
la maladie une transparence sanitaires
et politiques peu répandue en asie
notamment en chine depuis le début de
l'année la grippe aviaire a tué 32
personnes en thaïlande et au vietnam